fun fact James did you know that in many
parts of the world names are capitalized
differently while Americans capitalize
the first letter of both names and many
places of the world the first name has
the first letter capitalized while the
last name is entirely capitalized really
I guess that does make sense in some
countries I know that they list the
family name first in the first name
second then it probably makes sense if
our resumes could switch to
international mo to do the same yeah
this sounds like an interesting
challenge first off append the
internationalized button to the main div
this is just a string with HTML that
will create a button then create a
function called in name that takes a
string of two names and returns an
internationalized version that would
look something like this when you're
done check this button you should be
able to see the new internationalized
names show up on the resume every time
you click the button